[Music]
my name is sergei sukarenko I'm a
product manager at the Google cloud and
today with me I have George Villiers
vice president to sigma talking to you
about advancing serverless data
processing in cloud dataflow by
separating state and compute storage but
before we talk about separating compute
and state storage I wanted to do a very
very quickly a historical perspective of
how the industry used to process really
large data sets in the past imagine it's
the year 2000 and you have a one
petabyte large data set that you want to
process Oh Who am I kidding in the year
2000 I read a large data set was
probably something you're measured in
terabytes well still you have a terabyte
of data and you want to process it and
it's the year 2000 so it probably used
something like this an architecture
something like this you would use a
large box with lots of CPU and with some
might be a mainframe or a UNIX box and
the storage would be provided through a
storage area network then come 2004 new
distributed processing frameworks very
least and and now you would probably be
using a cluster of cheap Linux nodes
with storage actually being part of that
processing node so local storage then as
things moved into the cloud you were
still using these clusters of Linux
nodes but now you would be using a
network attached storage provided by the
cloud provider in 2010 Google published
a white paper we call the drama paper
which defined the new architecture for
processing really large web scale data
sets and that architecture was based on
the following idea you would have a
independent highly available cluster of
compute you know you would have highly
reliable storage facility in 2011 we
launched the product
was based on this white paper on this
concept we called it bigquery and
probably this conference if you heard
about bigquery many many times became a
very successful product so this is the
architecture of bigquery
it has the concepts described in the
Dremel white paper it has a replicated
storage layer it has a highly available
cluster of compute they are separate
they're working together and they're
connected through a very fast petabyte
scale network but there's a component in
this architecture that was not part of
the original Dremel paper it's the
distributed in memory shuffled here now
you might ask yourself what is the
shuffle why why was it added later on
when we actually launched the product
into general availability so let's just
quickly cover the concept of shuffle
with shuffle or in data processing when
you have a collection a big collection
of key value pairs and you want to do a
grouping grouping or join with another
data set you need to sort these elements
and when you have a single node
processing architecture you can easily
sort it more or less I didn't memory you
can sort your data set in memory by key
or you have on disk efficient on the
sorting algorithms
unfortunately when once your data sets
explode and you have to move it to a
distributed framework or distributed
architecture where you have lots of
nodes it becomes somewhat more complex
so you your end goal is to have
everything sorted by key and all data
elements associated with the particular
key collocated on a particular worker
node and what you end up doing is you
end up shuffling or physically moving
data elements associated with specific
keys from one box to another and that's
the process of shuffling now as you can
imagine this is a very resource
intensive and time intensive process and
as your data set scale it becomes
more and more complex that's why
bigquery ended up building a separate
dedicated component that was just
responsible for shuffling big datasets
and it became critical a critical
component that connected the storage as
well as the compute compute nodes now I
am a product manager of dataflow and
this is a data flow related question so
you might ask yourself why am i spending
so much time talking about shuffle we
actually in data for health have the
same problem we are providing the same
data transformations to customers we
allow them to do groupings and joins and
aggregations and filtering and
projections so the problem set is
actually quite similar to what bigquery
is dealing with here's a screenshot of a
real data flow pipeline let's just
follow this pipeline as it lives in our
service simplistically it can be
represented by this diagram we have a
couple of data sources we have data
transformations that's the green things
over there and then we have group joins
and group buys that's a special kind of
a data transformation and finally the
data ends up in a data sync so as you
submit this data flow job to our service
cloud data flow we are going to create a
cluster of nodes to process it and this
will be compute engine virtual machines
and will also use a persistent disk
storage and we're going to start reading
from sources once here once we hit the
green boxes the data transformations
they're gonna run them on compute and
use some local storage and then when
things enter the the joints and the
group buys we're actually gonna do a
shuffle and we're gonna do the shuffle
today using persistent storage either
the magnetic type or SSD type whatever
the customer specifies ultimately data
gets written into sinks and we shut down
the cluster and that's kind of in in a
nutshell how a dataflow job works
now in data flow as I said we are
dealing with the same kinds of volume
and scalability issues that bigquery is
dealing with we have huge volumes of
data that customers want to process and
so we ended up implementing a very
similar mechanism for a distributed in
memory shuffle service in data flow and
the service works like this you have
your compute clusters and they run you
user code which you write out in Java or
Python let me have the data flow shuffle
and the data flow shuffle is deployed
for high availability reasons into
multiple GCP regions so in each tcp
region we our data flow shuffle is
available we also have replication and
duplication of shuffle in in every zone
we have a deployed in Arizona we have a
component we call the auto zone
placement and this component decides
based on the available capacity and the
job which zone it needs to be a center
so we take care of deciding which which
don't run and then we have a trio of
components which coordinate the actual
shuffle operation but among themselves
we have a shuffle proxy which accepts
the job and we have two memory systems
one is a I'm sorry we have to file
systems one is in memory and the other
one is on disk and so if your job and
the available capacity kind of allows us
to do a shuffle entirely in memory your
data will never touch disk and will
quickly return results to you but if
your job is size such as that we that we
have to care some of this data on disk
we gonna transparently move some of your
data from in memory and to disk and then
shuffle it there for you you don't have
to worry about anything we do
transparent shuffling and which is three
two and results to you so this entire
architecture requires no code changes
from users you can tell us just by
specifying a parameter that you want to
use the data flow shuffle and we are
going to switch from the
he debased shuffle the one that we
discussed just earlier in the talk to a
service-based shuffle transparently to
you and today I'm very happy to announce
general availability of data for shuffle
and to GCP regions in US central one and
us West one data for shuffle has been a
beta for for a while now it's available
generally to 200 users let's quickly go
through the benefits of data flow
shuffle the first benefit is many of our
customers tell us that shuffle is now
much faster than it used to be so if we
if we take the same pipeline and compare
the execution times of this pipeline
using magnetic discs magnetic PD then
SSD PD and the data flow shuffle the
shuffle service you're gonna see that
the kind of magnetic disks give you
maybe 55 minutes of duration in your
pipeline execution now the tuned
pipeline the one that is using SSD PD PD
is persistent disks will run in
approximately 17 minutes the data flow
shuffle 1 will actually run in ten
minutes
these results are not always applicable
to every use case but many many of our
customers are telling us that's what
they'd seen the other benefit of
dataflow shuffle is that we are now able
to process and shuffle much larger
datasets and you're going to see in a
demo the sizes of shuffles we can we can
now support the if previously the
untuned jobs the ones that used magnetic
disks were able to shuffle tens of
terabytes of data and jobs that used SSD
PD it is able to shuffle up to 50
terabytes of data now we can push in to
hundreds of terabytes so with this I
wanted to show your demo that actually
runs a shuffle job and here's how the
the job looks like I have two inputs to
GCSE buckets a dataset in in GCSE
buckets and I'm going to
need a fifty terabyte dataset in each
case in each of the inputs and I'm gonna
join them and write them into a GCS
bucket the code for this pipeline is
written in Scala using a framework that
one of our customers developed it's
called Shira Spotify at the original
developers of this framework and I like
sure because it allows me to very easily
define my my pipelines the entire
pipeline is these 10 to 15 lines of code
for those of you who might not see it
let me just quickly explain what it does
in the main function I define my first
input in my second input and then I do a
left outer join and I write the file
write output to files
that's all this pipeline does and let me
switch to the demo station and actually
show you how sorry before we switch the
demonstration you might ask me yourself
how do how does the input work here's a
screenshot of the of one of the files
that I will be joining it consists of
three columns the first column is the
key that's the key I want to join on and
it's just random generated strings then
I have a record ID and have billions of
records in my data set and so this
record ID is pretty long it's a very
long string and then I have the payload
the value that I want to associate with
the key and so with this let's switch to
the demonstration and let me run a few
commands
great so I'm in in bash in terminal and
I've got the first thing I want to show
you is the contents of my bucket from
which I will be region files I've
defined a variable batch variable input
50 TBS and this is the this is the
bucket that contains 50 terabytes worth
of files so I have fifty thousand one
gigabyte large files that have data with
random keys that I will be joining
together and just to show you that this
bucket really contains 50 TBS
I ran a listing command and here's my
here's my proof it does really contain
50 terabytes I'm not gonna run now
because if I if I ran I than listing 50
thousand files will actually take
several minutes that's why I ran it
before now my next command is the one
that will create the pipeline and I'm
gonna be using the scalability tool to
quickly execute from the command line
the command that launches a dataflow job
and as you can see what I need to
specify here is what is my input and the
first and both of the inputs will be
reading from the scene bucket the output
bucket and the parameter instruction the
dataflow service to use the shuffle
service so I'm gonna run this command
and so then I'm in order to the the code
will be packaged all of the dependencies
will be deployed and I'm gonna initiate
my job I'll give it a few seconds
depending on the Wi-Fi gods if I feel
lucky it will it will be done quickly
but in any case I also ran a shuffle
just before the demo a shuffle that did
100 terabytes of that processed 100
terabytes so here's my job just to give
you a few
data points about this job the job took
500 belen elements in my dataset it was
about 51 terabytes in the second input I
had also 500 billion rows another 51 and
then I joined them in this separation
and data flow we call joins Co group by
Keys and so it created 100
I think billion combinations of these
keys some of the keys overlapped some of
them didn't and then I brought them out
into files and I actually created two
point five trillion lines in my output
2.5 trillion almost 1 petabyte of
outputs and this job took about seven
and a half hours and I was able to
process it with ten lines of code back
to my slides please so hopefully I was
able to show you that now it's very very
easy to to do large-scale shuffle
processing with cloud dataflow in
addition to my 100 terabyte run I also
ran a few smaller jobs just to show you
the scalability of this process so I did
a photo rabbit run a 20 terabyte run and
the 100 terabytes run with 5x data
entries every time and the execution
time was pretty much linear which which
is what we want to have you don't want
to have a quadratic escalation of your
duration if you can achieve linearity an
execution time that's a very very good
result what you don't see on this slide
is that the resources that you consumed
during this execution what we call
shuffle data processed also skilled
skilled linearly so you'll be
if your difference indeed is you know 2x
you will only pay 2x more for such a job
it's another good property of of a
service if you're able to scale both
duration as well as cost linearly as UD
the project progresses now we talked
about batch pipelines and hopefully I
was able to show you that in batch
processing being able to to do a fashion
shuffling is important but what about
steaming processing code dataflow
provides both batch and steaming
capabilities and perhaps in steaming you
also need shuffle you might ask the
answer is yes you it's it's also very
important to be able to do shuffling in
steaming pipelines because customers
want to join and group data elements but
in addition to shuffling in steaming
pipeline the other thing that is
important is that you need to be able to
efficiently store state state as it
relates to Windows 10 Windows that you
create when you're on windowing
aggregations on steaming data so let's
go through a similar life of us of a
pipeline but for for a steaming use case
so this pipeline leads from pops up does
a windowing operation by even time does
a grouping does a group by does an
aggregation account account aberration
and then writes into a bigquery now the
first thing to know here is that when we
when you submit such such a job to data
flow we're going to divide it into three
stages everything that comes before the
group by everything that comes after the
group by and the actual shuffle step and
once we divide it into three portions
we're going to start thinking how do we
scale and distributed this processing
and our way of distributing the incoming
workload to multiple workers is by
partitioning your data set by key if
your pipeline already has a key through
maybe a group by operation will use that
key if it doesn't have a group by then
will auto-generate the key and partition
your data that way so in this case for
example
we have split the key spaces for the
three for the P shuffle and a Porsche
for operations interchanges and we're
gonna I'm gonna show you next what we're
gonna do with these ranges well they're
going to assign them to workers so each
key range will be assigned to an
individual worker once we done the
assignment of key ranges to workers we
are going to persist the data and make
specific pd volumes responsible for
storage of data as they relate to these
key keys and key ranges when we have to
scale a pipeline in a steaming case
we're actually going to move an entire
disk from one worker to the other we're
not going to try to rearrange key spaces
and compress them on reassign them
you're going to take an entire disk an
entire resistant disk and reassign it to
another worker as you can imagine it's a
another time intensive operation
steaming out of scaling has been working
for many customers really really well
but in some cases it might end up being
a little bit sluggish because we have to
reassign disks now we talked about group
by let's quickly cover the window
inebriation and here it's important to
remember in steaming there are two
important time dimensions that you want
to think about the first time dimension
is your business time dimension that's
the event time this is when the sales
transaction happened if you if you're
dealing with sales today transactions or
it might be the time when the user
clicked on a link so it's the business
time and in our terminology we call it
event time the other important time
dimension is processing time that's the
time when the business transaction
enters the processing pipeline and as
you can imagine that could be delays
between an event generated by the source
system and the same event entering a
processing pipeline now what many
customers want to do they don't want to
deal with processing time as a unit
of analysis or is a dimension of
analysis they actually want to deal with
avantime and they want to organize the
data elements into windows windows of
either fixed duration or configurable
duration or session based windows but
they want to group their data elements
by event time so with this in mind what
we have to do on the data flow side to
allow such an analytic analytical
processing we end up buffering data
elements on on disk because we have to
store these elements until the window
closes closes and we can initiate the
processing of elements in the window so
in addition to shuffle we also do we
also store data elements related to two
windows so we asked ourselves can we do
something similar for streaming
pipelines as we did for the batch
pipelines with shuffle and the answer is
yes I'm happy to announce that today we
made the steaming engine available in
data in two regions in US central one
and euro past one quickly about the
benefits of the steaming engine and the
architecture of the streaming engine you
use the code the code that you write
that represents your business logic
continues to run on worker nodes but now
all the plumbing all the streaming
plumbing that used to run and Quran and
coexist with your user code that used to
run on the worker nodes it has been
moved to a dedicated service and
Google's back-end and it is responsible
for two things it's responsible for
Windows state storage as well as for
streaming shuffle your user code
communicates transparently you as a
developer you don't have to think about
it or worry about it very similarly to
dataflow shuffle and batch keys you only
have to provide us with a parameter that
tells us that you want us to use the
steaming engine so your user code
transparently communicates with this
back-end and we do all the shuffling and
all the state storage for you
the benefits are we don't have to move
around discs anymore if you want to
scale so out of scaling and steaming
became much much better we also can do
maintenance on our service much easier
it doesn't interrupt you you can
continue running your pipeline we can do
maintenance and patches on the back end
without interrupting you in most cases
and we also consume less resources on
the worker nodes so now your user code
that does that implements business
transactions and does process your data
element has more CPU and memory
available to it so it can produce more
and crunch to more data here's an
example that shows you how streaming out
of skilling works together with the
streaming engine and what this diagram
shows you is a incoming steaming
incoming stream of data the trend for
bout one hour
entrenched in bandwidth and throughput
between one megabyte per second to ten
megabytes per second when I didn't use
the streaming engine cloud dataflow
scaled my workers and initially it
started with three workers and then once
once data flow sensed as a increase in
incoming data its killed the number of
workers to fifteen it kept this number
for a while and then scaled down and
then waited for another spike in inputs
and then scaled up now if you compare
this graph to the graph with with the
streaming engine as you can see we used
less workers and we were able to scale
down much faster here the two graphs
overlaid and it shows you quite nicely
how the steaming engine is able to avoid
scaling down to high numbers of
resources is using less resources and is
also more responsive to variations in
incoming data rate of course the best
stories about data flow
I told by our customers and
I'm very happy to invite today George
Hiller's from 2 Sigma who will be
talking to you about how to Sigma is
using called beautiful thanks Sergey so
my name is George Helios I'm a vice
president at 2 Sigma so just a quick
intro to who 2 Sigma is we're a
Manhattan based hedge fund we take a
scientific approach to investing we hire
scientists mathematicians engineers the
works our mission is to find value in
the world's data so in particular I head
our engineering group that deals with
granular economic data I'm probably
getting some squints from OCU so let me
explain what what that kind of means
here's an example the NOAA publishes a
wealth of information publicly there's a
weather forecast about all regions of
the United States and so we have a big
question can we correlate weather
activity with you know regional
economics to predict financial outcomes
these are the types of questions data
scientists and engineers in my group ask
and so this data tend to be very large I
actually jump slides a little too
quickly sorry the the NOAA data
compressed is about a terabyte or so but
when you expand it and look at all the
rows of data this is into the hundreds
of terabytes so it's very very large to
make sense of that
so what do we do with all the this data
so it we we can do a lot of things with
this like we can do geospatial analysis
aggregate billions of rows of data
terabytes of data ultimately to build
alpha models so this type of work is you
know very lucrative it's very satisfying
however there's a weakness there we get
a lot of our data from third-party
vendors and so we're at risk of bad
vendor data causing bad predictions so
at 2 Sigma we take data quality very
seriously we build in anomaly detection
Xin to all of our pipelines to guard
herself against these bad outcomes
now when you're dealing with data at
this scale we have to build very complex
high scale systems to detect these
anomalies and protect us and our
investors and so this is where data flow
enters we really don't want to be in the
business of building infrastructure we'd
like to focus our energy on business
logic things nuance to particular
vendors and the types of quirks they
threw our way but also you know we're
not a particularly large team we don't
have the resources go Google tends to
throw at these infrastructure type
problems so can a team of 10 to 20
engineers deal with hundred 200 terabyte
data sets without batting an eye and so
let me take a quick little sidebar here
how many of you know what RFC 4180 is
I'll be surprised to see any hands out
there so I do and this is the format for
CSV files these are comma separated
values it's the bread and butter in the
industry for how files are distributed
unfortunately our vendors do not tend to
know what that RFC is let me show you an
example of what that really entails and
these are these are real examples
obviously changed for presentation
purposes so that comma is that
separating two numbers or is that 15,600
in this case it was actually 15,600 good
luck to the pipeline understanding that
within the same file dates represented
in different ways here is a newline
character is that a separate row or is
that the same string that happens have a
new line in it a lot of these vendors
get their data from third-party sources
to them and they're just passing it
along so if it's unescape Tan Dun quoted
any off-the-shelf CSV parser will choke
on this and here's another one we've
noticed that
Oh as the days and months go by vendors
decide to expose new fields to us to the
schema changes so imagine you're a data
engineer you're writing a pipeline and
you have your code for doing aggregation
do you have a line a conditional in
there that says if date is less than
january 1st 2016 I only expect four rows
right this all your pipelines would be
littered with this vendor specific logic
and it gets very unwieldy very quickly
so we wanted to take use this
opportunity with a tool like dataflow to
eliminate this problem entirely and get
in front of it so let me show you an
example of what that looks like we built
some tooling which we called the
normalizer very creative naming we use
on top of dataflow and the very first
step up here really involves taking the
list of files and a JSON file we call
the schema as input I'll go into details
of what that schema file kind of looks
like in the next slide but it's things
like the first field has this name and
has this type like string or integer it
has hooks for Python user-defined
functions for doing custom things etc in
the second step we implemented a custom
file source it takes a file as input
from GCS and it turns it into a P
collection which is a beam Apache beam
slash data flow concept a P collection
of generic type which is an Avro object
that has a schema again we we want to
use open source where possible to
leverage the innovations and the
contributions of the broader community
so we turn everything into an object of
a type a much later in the pipeline we
split this the stuff that goes one
direction or all the rows that we
successfully parse that we applied our
our our logic to normalize and put
everything to a schema and we use the
same Spotify library Sergei mentioned
earlier Co to save it as a park a file
there's another functionality in there
that I particularly appreciate is that
you can say
I want 5 million rows in every single
Park a file which if for those who have
done spark that there's actually kind of
a hard thing to do generally so when we
output our park' files and process them
downstream with all the files being very
evenly distributed your processing times
you make much better use of your
resources the other output I want to
call out because this is the hard-earned
experience that our data engineering
team has built up over time we output an
extra file that includes summary
statistics also show an example this
things like the total number of rows the
the number of error rows that we
encountered and so on and even more
importantly say you're on support you
get page in the middle of the night and
there's a failure there's a spike in
errors you'd like to have a file you go
to that contains all of the rows that
you saw that we're invalid
maybe the vendor got bored and wanted to
throw a new quirk your way
I'm laughing but because it's true
and finally I'm I'm super proud to
announce that a partnership between us
and Google we really wanted to get
Parque loading directly into bigquery
and Google pulled through big time here
so we not only can produce these park'
files but we can load them to bigquery
so imagine having all your raw vendor
data in bigquery to do your research on
to investigate failures etc and then if
your aggregation is sort of simple or
sequel base you can just let the Google
infrastructure handle it for you
furthermore since these are all open
source technologies park' etcetera the
data are small you can feed it into
Panos if the data are big and nuanced
you can feed it to spark we have one
thing up front that handles all of this
it's a big deal for us so here's an
example of a schema file I talked about
earlier you know there's a few different
types here that first one is a date time
in a very standard format an integer
containing the number of seconds since
UNIX epoch January 1st 1970 and very
standard standard convention here way of
a string we have a string hash that
takes its input another column we found
that if you're prime
very key or your foreign key is a string
that's very compute-intensive to do
joins or group bys on and so with our
standard upfront processing we can hash
a string as input and add a new column
there so when it gets loaded to bigquery
we have the hash as well as the source
and then when we process and spark those
groups are very fast and finally a null
ability some fields are optional and we
want to make it clear which one should
be treated as failures so here's an
example of our output in this summary
file I'm super proud of the the work the
team did because this this particular
vendor gave us over a trillion rows of
data and this is one of our days worth
of delivery
we were successfully able to parse 916
million records and we did this in a
matter of hours on data flow it scaled
very linearly there's a hundred
eighty-five park' files you can kind of
see behind the circle
they're very evenly sized this is great
for spark processing and the error rows
is zero because we had no failures that
day very powerful so let's tie this all
together we have the data from the
vendor they give it to us
FTP s3 GCS carrier Pidgeon whatever they
want to do we first store it in GCS and
then process it in data flow this is
where we do our normalization turn it
into parquet and output our summary
statistics we then run our ingestion
checks like I mentioned earlier we care
deeply about data quality in two
segments so we do things like fail if we
have a spike or a sharp decline in the
number of rows processed or the number
of errors encountered ideally we have
zero errors but sometimes if you're
processing a billion rows you sort of
shrug at five failed rows that's the
sort of the reality of the situation and
last but not least we load to bigquery
for analysis research and further
processing so I do want to highlight
some high-level benefits we get here so
a small team like ours can process a ton
of data with very little effort and that
trillion data
Road
a set example I told you earlier we
tried it and spark previously and it
took a thousand workers two weeks to
crank through everything and this is a
pretty simple algorithm just parsing
strings and turning me to parquet and
data flow we did the whole data set in
one to two days one other benefit is we
don't have to manage any of the
infrastructure we just sort of write our
beam pipeline and set it to Google and
there's one more thing I want to
highlight there Sergey talked earlier
about cloud shuffle we found to just we
should just turn it on so either the
data set is small enough to where
shuffles not invoked you can see on the
UI there's a number of bytes shuffled if
this number is small you don't really
pay much of anything for it but when the
debt when that number is big and your
data set is very large we've seen
pipelines take half much less time to
run which saves you on compute and
storage costs thank you but let's wrap
this up hopefully we were you able to
see how having a separate separate
distributed in memory processing
mechanism for shuffle improves the
efficiency of separating compute from
storage that was key for both batch and
steaming pipelines we have a new service
available for you today dataflow shuffle
and new components are another new
service we are not launching any service
so for batch pipelines we have a new
option for you dataflow shuffle that
makes your pipelines run faster and
you're now able to process much larger
data sets and shuffle much larger data
sets for the steaming pipelines we have
the streaming engine and it improves the
scalability of your streaming pipelines
both of these features are available in
two GCP regions in your central one and
Europe West one thank you very much and
we would be happy to take questions
either over microphone or later on after
the session
[Music]